hey max hat mich gebeten euch eine
aufgabe für eure erste prognose stellen
und da bin ich natürlich gerne
behilflich auch wenn euch das ergebnis
alles andere als gefallen wird geht
jetzt sofort zum auto im auto für zwei
von mir für euch vorbereitet rucksäcke
und fahrt zu den koordinaten die sich
ebenfalls geschickt aber dazu
[Musik]
doch
erst mal ganz kurz vor weckt uns sind
aufnahmen verloren gegangen ist ein
neues format das sich mit max jetzt jede
zwei wochen hochladen werde eine folge
bei ihm und eine folge bei mir hierbei
werden maxime nicht immer wieder in
verrückten challenges gegeneinander
antreten bis zum challenge statt weiß
einfach keiner von uns worum es geht und
die aufgaben kommen meistens von
freunden von uns dieses mal kam die
aufgabe von seppl und selbst auf dem weg
zu den koordinaten wussten wir noch
nicht genau worum es geht wir sind so es
vom auto ich weiß nicht was uns erwartet
ihr euch wundert in diesem rucksack ist
nur um ein ganzes kamera equipment ich
hab nichts anderes dabei bin gespannt
was uns in den rucksäcken erwartet aber
es ist schon ziemlich offensichtlich wir
haben einen schlafsack in dem rucksack
und eine angel an der seite also viele
möglichkeiten scheint es nicht zu geben
gehen jetzt erst mal zum nächsten spot
an dem wir dann endlich den rucksack
aufmachen dürfen und die finale aufgabe
erhalten glaube und irgendwo sein
das wird so sein wenn die sachen einmal
nass sind unser schlafsack hängt schon
hinten an unserer rucksack während wir
im regen laufen zu ende bevor sie
angefangen hat
was machst du jetzt aber wieder ein
bisschen dichter aber das ist ganz gut
während des regens ich hab's ja dass
hier sieht mir nach einem feinsten
lagerplatz für mich ausbauen
mein gott geil hier
oder wäre also bei den kunden angekommen
sehr gut packt jetzt die rucksäcke aus
die challenge endet morgen um 12 wer bis
zum ende durchhält bekommt den ersten
ich hoffe dass wir irgendwas planmäßiges
haben einfach weil ich so viel kram
dabei habt ihr nicht nass werden da vor
allem meine klamotten weil sonst die
nacht ziemlich unentspannt wird aber
werden sehen sagt jetzt nicht einfach
nach glaube dafür suche ich mir als
allererstes ein trockenes plätzchen
irgendwo unter einem baum oder einem
gebüsch das hier ausgenommen des
schlafsacks ist jetzt unser komplettes
proviant für diese nacht was wir direkt
aufgefallen ist wir haben eine angel
inklusive eines kompletten angel setzt
hier sind köder hier sind haken hier
sind schwimmer hier ist alles drin ich
habe mal 2013 angelschein gemacht davon
weiß ich nicht mehr so viel aber es
sollte vielleicht reichen um fisch zu
fangen aber da kümmern wir uns später
und leben diesen wunderbaren rucksack
der sich wirklich phänomenal tragen
lässt finden wie
als erstes eine plane ok sehr gut das
allerwichtigste entweder wir finden
jetzt gleich noch irgendwie ein zelt
oder das hier wird das einzige sein was
wir haben heute nacht trocken und mit
einem dach über dem kopf zu schlafen
zwei mal zwei meter fünfzig das sollte
eigentlich reichen ohneis okay max wir
sind safe wir haben zweimal portionen
essen einmal pasta bolognese in einmal
reis mit schicken das sind so was wie so
ein mann packungen jetzt nicht wirklich
von der bundeswehr aber so sehen die aus
bild sechs minuten war ist was da haben
wir zu fechten hertha bei sony haben wir
zufällig feuer
es regnet bei mir sieht auch nicht so
aus als hätte ich irgendwas drin womit
das wasser heiß machen könnte da führen
wir ein top eine flasche wasser eine
kopflampe 2 mal 10 meter seil damit wir
alles abspannen können und so kost
antritt 2 nicht über dem ich diverse
videos gesehen habe wie man so eine tat
baut und das werden wir definitiv hier
mit dieser plane machen eine hängematte
als auch eine hängematte ja wir wollen
wir euch ja ich danke dir seppelt ist
wechsel aus dem unser traum natürlich
findet ihr max sicht und alles was max
macht bei max auf dem kanal der erste
link in der video beschreibung führt
euch zu dem video freuen das mit
geisteskrank okay waren bei maxxim den
rucksack geschaut er hatte auch eine
planer dabei wenn es als allererstes die
planer ausgelegt um alle unsere
rucksäcke und den ganzen kram darunter
zupacken vielleicht ist das schloss
damit zusammenarbeiten und uns gemeinsam
darum kümmern dass bei dir erstmal die
sachen im trockenen sind und wer jetzt
erstmal meinen sprach ich glaube es ist
eine gute idee wenn wir uns gegenseitig
halt nur wenn du mir auch hilft es geht
hier um punkte ich will den punkt haben
aber ich glaube ohne uns gegenseitig zu
helfen erstmal schaffen wir es beide
nicht hast du eine ahnung von knoten ich
habe bei fritz meinecke immer zugeschaut
und die knoten gibt wer konnte auch
davon ausgehen dass wir es irgendwann
brauchen die hängematte relativ niedrig
und direkt darüber ein seil was sich der
länge nach spanien wo ich das tat
komplett einfach drüber legen kann ich
das nur einmal an jeder ecke ab und dann
sollte das schon kommt nur erreichen
da hat man bevor du weitermachst wir
müssen erst die schnur durch die
vorletzte anfänger live ich bin ganz
froh dass wir das gerade bei dir schon
so ein bisschen sehen wie du probierst
sich da heraus zu finden
glaube es hat gerade durch zufall und
wochen gefunden der bomben festhält und
den mann mit einem zug wieder auf
bekommt vielleicht kann man das
irgendjemand sagen für das gefühl wenn
ich jetzt hier dran ziehen würde sich
hier die schlaufe raus und kann den
knoten direkt wieder öffnen nach
deutlich mehr arbeit und über einer
stunde stehen unsere beiden tat also
meint sieht so aus ich bin ziemlich
zufrieden ich habe heringe gebaut die
einfach hier zu abgespannt sieht sehr
gut aus aber natürlich hängt meine
schlafmöglichkeit noch nicht an sich
scheint das aber ganz gut zu sein ich
habe keine stellen die nicht irgendwie
krass gespannt sind oder so was
natürlich dazu führen könnte dass sich
wasser irgendwo staudt oder das irgendwo
durchhängt ich glaube so könnte das
funktionieren mag sie läuft zwei dir das
los dieser baum ist viel zu dick viel zu
dick cook jetzt andere an ist ein traum
ehrlich geht jetzt gerade um die
hängematten befestigung perfekt und auf
der anderen seite
du kriegst erstmal das sei aber ich habe
ihm gefallen weil dir offen zu überleben
im wald ist es wahrscheinlich nur zu
tauschen und nicht leuten einfach
irgendwas zu schenken und ich muss
gewinnen
plötzlich post aus wachs auf dem boden
schlafen oder mitten in der nacht seinen
heußlein umbauen
[Musik]
jetzt circa anderthalb stunden unseren
unterschlüpfe aufgebaut und jetzt
kommt's zum großen vergleich mag sich
gerade irgendwo hier im wald unterwegs
und sucht nach ersatz stücke die er als
ersatz karabiner über nutzen kann
das bedeutet wir können perfekt in
seinem eigenheim reinschauen seine
hängematte hängt ziemlich tief für
meinen geschmack das bedeutet wenn er
hier drin liegt hat er nicht mehr den
schutz von den seitenwänden des tages
ich habe probiert das ein bisschen
anders zu machen vielleicht ein bisschen
zu optimistisch meine hängematte hängt
da um
ich weiß nicht wo wir die sehen könnt
ganz da oben drin ich habe aber das
gefühl dass wenn ich mich reinlegen dass
sie deutlich weiter nach unten kommt und
ich so ziemlich genau auf der perfekten
höhe rauskommen werde das testverbot
hier ist meine hängematte entwickelt
es kracht es klappt es klappt und hänge
genau wie es mir vorgestellt habe ich
bin quasi windgeschützt ich bin regen
geschützt ich habe hier wirklich mein
eigenes haus zusammengebaut innerhalb
von anderthalb stunden des echten
komplett krank das feeling also ich kann
komplett verstehen warum sich so viele
leute dafür begeistern einfach raus zu
gehen in den wald zu gehen in der natur
zu sein sich selber irgendwas zu bauen
selber nach lösungen zu suchen wenn man
auf probleme stößt was wir natürlich
auch beim aufbau an der einen oder
anderen stelle hatten jetzt kümmern wir
uns aber erstmal um unsere versorgung
zum aller ersten mal gehen wir hier
vorne ans wasser oh mein gott walther
ist das große halter ist das riesig
wollte gerade ganz entspannt ein runde
da drohen hier drehen während max das
essen vorbereitet hat das problem diese
beiden dinge passen gut zusammen und wir
können unser essen nicht wahr machen das
wiederum bedeutet dass wir das essen
kalt essen müssen also nudeln und kann
mit kaltem wasser und wahrscheinlich
sogar wasser aus diesem see weil wir
nicht mehr genug haben und jetzt kommt
es zu meiner stärke ausharren und max
dem jetzt dieser luxus fehlt wird es
deutlich deutlich schlechter geht als
mir
ja auf jeden fall sehr guter tipp dass
wir unser licht mitnehmen sollten das
hilft uns jetzt riesig damit wir hier
noch ein bisschen was für euch fühlen
können wir haben kein essen
trotz alledem werde ich jetzt meine
route aus schmeißen und hoffen dass ich
einen fischfang und nicht dann um feuer
kümmern das ist zwar ziemlich schwer
weil es hat in den letzten tagen viel
geregnet und alles ist nass ich bin aber
ziemlich optimistisch dass es klappen
könnte
ich habe in den untiefen eines rucksacks
dann noch ein feuerzeug gefunden also
eigentlich müsste es irgendwie
funktioniert das ding ist unser
abendessen hängt von so krass vielen
variablen
erstmal muss ich das hier irgendwie
hinbekommen mit dieser angel haben muss
irgendwie speisen und dann müssen wir
noch ein feuer an bekommen die
wahrscheinlichkeit ist relativ gering
aber wer nicht wagt der nicht gewinnt
und zeit sollten auch glück haben weil
ich wüsste auch nicht was jetzt sonst
machen wir freunde zum einen und
auswerfen bist du gerade ins wasser
getreten
ich werde langsam aufgeben so viel wir
bei dir schief läuft nichts gefangen
gut dass wir jetzt immer sehen können
wenn jemand hat sich jemand der achim
zum beispiel ausgeworfen erfolgreich
haben wir ab jetzt irgendjemand oder
irgendetwas beißen wird das bezweifelt
aber wenn wir wir sehen uns wieder wenn
ich einen fisch gefangen habe ich glaube
da ist was dran
[Musik]
ich habe dem ganzen jetzt zwei stunden
zeit gegeben ich habe diverse male diese
route ausgeworfen und das hat natürlich
rein gar nichts gebracht wer hätte es
gedacht wäre schlau und hat es einfach
überhaupt gar nicht erst versucht es lag
natürlich jetzt ging an zu regnen
deswegen machen wir uns möglichst
schnell unter unser dach und haben eine
möglichst trockene nacht bin sehr
gespannt max auch und max meckert seit
zwei stunden rum dass er eigentlich
schlafen gehen wir das ist soweit ich
habe gerade schon mein komplettes
bettfertig gemacht alles ein bisschen
aufgeräumt ein bisschen was aufgehängt
hier unten der große kamera rucksack
muss leider stehen weil er sonst hier
ein bisschen im regen hängt hier sehen
wir max schlafplatz davon will ich aber
nicht zu viel zeigen das seht ihr
natürlich bei ihm das hier ist mein
schlafplatz und sowie das netz im
fertigen zustand aus eigentlich ziemlich
gemütlich wie ist dein moment wirklich
ist werde ich gleich hier nicht rein
obwohl ich die ganze zeit mega
anstrengend war muss ich sagen das ist
überhaupt nicht müde werden das könnte
vielleicht daran liegen dass mich ein
bisschen mehr vor dem wechsel ins bett
zu gehen
die sind überall die ganze zeit
geräusche mir ist die ganze zeit so ein
bisschen latent kalt weil ich halt nass
geworden bin und geschwitzt habe das ist
wirklich
keine besonders gute kombination werde
mich in meinen gemach beginn irgendwie
rein kommt es funktioniert das
funktioniert einfach alle bis dato habt
schnell schuhe ausziehen ich will meine
taktik für die nacht damit maschinen
waren bleibe jetzt nicht laut sagen
max das nicht hört weil es gibt eine
spezielle taktik die ich etwas machen
wir hier alter um euch das kurz zu
demonstrieren so werde ich schlafen
mal sehen wie lange es dauert bis ich
wirklich schlafen mit 70 und ganze zeit
filme wegen irgendwelchen wildschwein
also es stimmt im letzten urlaub wurden
wir von wildschweinen besucht und haben
unser essen durchsucht
ich habe dann aber zum dank einfach
meine situation hier unten auf dem boden
liegen lassen es ist die große frage
magst benötigt schon wieder meine hilfe
es ist der start von go ist es schlimm
jetzt direkt solche eingeständnisse zu
machen und ihm so sehr zu helfen
ich bin quasi der einzige grund warum
max überhaupt jetzt noch da ist ja okay
das ist passiert aber ich würde außerdem
welt extra aufgestanden um ex abzufragen
vor dass auch fünf kilometer weiter
entfernt als sie und ich habe meine
erste station direkt unter meiner
hängematte gelegt damit die wildschweine
vorbeikommen können marx liegt wieder
auf ihr das sehen auch dieser seite der
tk 30 zentimeter tiefer als auf dieser
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir haben kurz vor 6 und wissenschaft
und praxis schon seit über einer halben
stunde war ziemlich genau so lange
bisher ist das hier irgend ein
vierbeiniges rumgerannt ist also
wirklich rumgerannt mit echt tempo wird
sich zumindest angehört ist bedeute dass
wir noch circa sechs stunden auszuharren
haben zum glück habe ich meine immer
noch nicht angepackt und die angel noch
nicht zusammengebaut ich werde mich
jetzt fertig machen zum wasser gehen
weiter angeln und frühstücken na ja eine
sache habe ich noch vergessen ziemlich
doof aber das schlimmste überstanden
auch für max leben geht es auch gut und
der ist immer noch da und macht auch
gerade keine anstalten jetzt irgendwie
das ganz abzubrechen auch wenn es sehr
standhaft aussieht wie er damit in sein
herz hänge zwar erwachsenen puls aber
ich hab es aus dem bett heraus geschafft
und werde mich als allererstes um die
angel und mein frühstück kommt es so wie
viel weiß nicht nur deutlich weniger
aber genug um es bis 12 uhr auszuhalten
wir haben 70 30 und ich hab machen wie
vor nicht gefrühstückt dafür meine ruht
aber schon des öfteren ausgeworfen die
liegt da vorne ich weiß nicht ob es
sehen könnt sieht wirklich geisteskrank
idyllisch aus heute gibt es zum
frühstück curry mit reis kalt ähnlich
wie bei max der geruch ist krass weil es
halt voll geballert ist mit
irgendwelchen gewürzen / wie nennt man
chemie ich habe halt auch keinen löffeln
ich habe keine andere möglichkeit und
mittlerweile habe ich wirklich hunger
also wirklich wirklich
gestern abend hatte ich schon
schwierigkeiten einzuschlafen mit diesem
hungergefühl
jetzt ist aber so dass ich gar nicht
mehr geht nicht
lara wird auch gar nichts mehr zu
trinken habe ich ein bisschen anders
forscht ich glaube ich hab dann hier so
ein lagerfeuer noch mit alter und
minuten im kalten wasser ziehen und in
der zeit
[Musik]
ich habe die ganze zeit beschäftigung
ich bin am angeln und krone blieb
und man versteht warum und hängt an
irgendwas zu schnitzen
was nicht weniger schlecht ist aber er
macht es halt aus langeweile und nicht
weil er lust hat irgendwas zu schlucken
es sieht nicht schlecht aus es hat echt
bisschen funktioniert komplett klar das
hat aber noch ein bisschen krank oder
aber wie kalter krieg träger dass er
komplett jetzt ja also es gibt wirklich
klar ist natürlich jetzt keinen drei
sterne menü aber um ein bisschen was im
magen zu bekommen ist perfekt und mit
dieser kulisse wird selbst das schlechte
essen zu einem wahren augenschmaus
artikel vom 10 wir kommen zu vor dem
ende immer mehr das macht mich aber
nicht besonders glücklich denn ich habe
keinen fisch wir haben 12 uhr 1 das
bedeutet wir haben es geschafft wir
haben es nicht nur geschafft die ganze
nacht hier zu bleiben und im trockenen
zu schlafen und mehr oder minder gut zu
essen sondern erste challenge geschafft
das heißt bei der nächsten was wir aber
extrem wichtig ist zu sagen wir sind in
den wald gekommen um diese erfahrung zu
machen das hat eine menge spaß gemacht
das wichtigste an dieser sache und der
höchste kodex dabei ist aber das wird im
wald genauso verlassen wir ihn
vorgefunden haben wir haben keinen
einzigen lebenden ast von einem baum
abgeschnitten haben nur kram gefunden
dass wir auf dem boden gefunden haben es
sieht so aus hamm wirklich keinen
einzigen chance hier hinterlassen wir
verlassen den wald genauso wie wir ihn
vorgefunden haben wenn ihr das machen
solltet macht das genauso und das war's
von dieser folge wenn es euch spaß
gemacht hat lass mir gerne like darum
hat es eine menge spaß gemacht wir sehen
uns in einer oder zwei wochen wieder zur
nächsten challenge von go mal gut